[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link
and i'm rhett this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we
are going through the surveys that were
given to
our individual wives we only have one
wife each
and uh we've been married for
20 and 21 years respectively we have
questions for them and apparently they
have lots of answers
now we did not come come up with these
questions
yeah because what would be the fun of
that uh
kiko and jenna you guys collaborated on
these questions right
just like with the kids and if you
didn't listen to our
we gave our kids a survey from last year
hey you can go back and listen to that
speaking of which
um the next three weeks we're taking a
break from fresh episodes of ear
biscuits
uh we're thinking that we're going to
re-release older episodes that you may
not have heard of and it'll just be an
easy way to prompt you to check it out
if you want to
but if not after this episode three
weeks
until the fourth week
will then be a fresh one again we'll be
back talking about more
and we'll be orienting you to to this
during because we will have a little
intro
that we record in the modern times to
introduce you to the episode that we're
going to be throwing back to
but look i mean in other podcasts that i
listen to that's what they do
and and i find that every time they
introduce an old old episode i'm like
yeah i haven't heard that one
but i also don't listen to every single
episode of a podcast so if you listen to
every single episode of your biscuits
first of all thank you thank you
but second of all you just skip the skip
those or just listen to them again what
do you just you know
just vacuum or how many podcasts
unicycle
have two guys who've been friends as
long as we have who've
who've submitted themselves to the
survey
questions uh of their wives i can't
think of any
so kiko and jenna as i was saying they
put together these questions
things that uh i think they thought
would be interesting
to hear uh christy and jesse
just give their just unfiltered opinion
and um okay now we just have to read
them and react
to it and respond to it so um
i'm ready i mean after last week we i
mean our
um our marriages seem to be good we seem
to be in like
we were saying at the end of the episode
it's like the best it's ever been
and now it's all being threatened by
this dumb survey idea
i do believe that though yeah that this
survey could could
be a divorce no i do believe
i'm not i'm not saying it's gotten it's
always gotten better
and i'm not saying there haven't been
very difficult times i'm just saying
certainly hasn't always gotten better
and it also
a lot of times when you're on a trip and
this may not apply to your recent trip
because your trip was shorter than mine
but
yeah when you're on a week-long trip
with just your spouse
let's just be honest sometimes it gets
to the end of it and
any vacation a lot of times you're kind
of just ready to go back home but jesse
and jesse and i made the note we were
like at the end of the trip we were like
i think it's a combination of
where we've been also the fact that
we're kind of like coming out of covid
and vacation is like such a
precious thing yeah but also where we
felt like our connection was we're like
man i wish we could do this for another
week so i mean
don't want to jinx it but yeah
i don't want to jinx the marriage oh
speaking of jinx
um ronstat the scripted podcast that
we're starring in
the sixth episode drops
on tuesday which is tomorrow when keep
listening if you listen to this on the
first day
there's a foursome uh in this episode
golf
do with that what you will listen to it
let's just let's just start at the
beginning and go through this thing okay
so the first question presented to our
wives
christy and jesse
is what is your husband's most
attractive trait
oh okay i like this i like the fact that
we started with a compliment now if i
would have been consulted
i might would have tweaked this question
to be like can you
list out all of your husband's
attractive traits that's why you weren't
consulted because
we would still be tweaking the list
right now okay and it's divided into
physical
physical trait and then character traits
so why don't we let's just start with a
physical oh okay it is
okay um okay christy said my most
attractive physical trait
is my eyeballs or may she just said eyes
maybe it's just like you agree with that
the inner part of the eye
when when you think about yourself
um are you like you know if if a lineup
of
just random people selected from earth
were to be
if i were to be paraded naked because
she's seen you naked so she knows
all the all the physical traits if you
were to be paraded
naked in front of just 1 000 random
people from
all around the world and they had to say
what your best trait was
do you think it would be your eyes
once you once you said i was naked like
i'm just picturing myself naked and i
was like am i going to say bush
that would be a funny joke bush yeah
[Applause]
well typically i would i i wouldn't say
bush but
you call it your bush no
typically i wouldn't say bush i didn't
say bush
i just said that i was considering it is
that is that not
a is that uh that's just for like a man
i mean i've only referred to uh women's
privates as a bush before
and only some women's uh i know that you
i know that you trim your uh
your leg here yeah very close might i
say
i know you you returned from a from a
pool trip it's a slippery slope man once
once you do it's basically shaved now i
want you to know what but
it's going to hit a sweet spot in
another week or so why don't you just
maintain the sweet spot but really i
don't want to trim my leg hair
i didn't shave it i would say the the
venn diagram
between men who trim their leg hair
yeah is almost a full crossover with men
who
trim their bush that has to be true you
know
yeah yeah yeah there's there's a
destination i would say
if i'm in this if i am an indicator
more men trim the bush than the leg hair
well yeah
it's a wink
don't tell me you're the opposite well i
the thing is i trim my my the hair off
my feet because
i hate having hobbit feet i just don't
like the look of it especially in the
summer when you're lounging by the pool
the hair on the top of my feet
especially the tear on the light the top
of my toes
fell out i mean like literally in the
past 15 years
what little you're sleeping in a tanning
top top of
uh top of foot here
it went away i don't i understand what
happened
i didn't dip my feet in a chemical well
i'm just saying if you don't remember
if you look at those extra like then my
toes in the
you know in my crotch at like the book
ends
i mean and once you have clippers at one
end
i just you know i just go through the
whole stack it's like everything's
better with less hair okay so
really what we're saying is that you use
the term bush inappropriately
you admit apparently you just didn't
even mean to say it you take it back
so back to the question what is it
called uh
well what were you talking about just
like the wiener are you talking about
above the wiener about above it
you think that peop a thousand people
selected in random at random from across
the world
who saw you naked would be like you know
right above his wiener
that's his best part i'm not talking
about that at all well that's the point
of the question i know you were asking
what's the proper terminology for a male
bush
not as weiner but just above his wiener
best trait on this random man who just
came out before us
now let's look at the next one he's
taller
yeah that's not what i was saying to
answer your question i don't know
i don't know my i would say okay my eyes
okay there you go i mean that is the
thing that
over the course of my life like aunts
and uncles would compliment me
you're such a strange person
you could have said you know women would
compliment me on my so my aunts and my
uncles are very
into my eyes you know when you're a kid
how do you guys uncles feel about your
bush you can't change no
no in the neil family you never know no
what do you what is that supposed to
mean
i'm just knowing family i'm saying
there's weird things that have happened
in your family
no no i'm saying like nothing nothing
like that is happening you lick your
aunt's face
yeah okay that's weird that's different
that's an inside joke
that's what she said what do you mean
that's what she said i'm listening
i'm not making the joke i'm saying
literally that's what your aunt said it
was an inside joke i'm not making the
office joke the michael scott joke
that's what she said
sometimes that's what she said is just
what she said
and sometimes the bush is on a guy this
is the first question
i haven't even given my answer yet what
did jesse say
is you're most attracted to physical
trait
i don't know how to feel about this
because she said his
luscious locks now let me what do you
mean you don't know how to feel about it
i don't know how to feel about it
because i haven't had these luscious
locks until like
the past 12 months so what was she
attracted to up until this point
well she was patient my bush let's not
okay this can't be the last bush no i
didn't bring it up
i didn't bring it up i actually didn't
either i said i was gonna bring it up
but i didn't actually break but i did
hear there is a new george bush that's
running
for office i think george p bush
[Laughter]
really that's what she said no exactly
i'm not going to say that ever again i
should have never said it you almost
being annoying yeah right
how does it feel i just want you to
understand
okay so um his luscious locks she likes
my hair she's made it very clear
and i'm happy i'm happy that i'm able to
give my wife that gift late in life you
know my twilight years
then i'm able to sprout this from my
head you're losing it on your toes you
might be losing it
and when i talk about potentially
cutting it because it's annoying and
i don't like dealing with it um she's
made it very clear and now she's made it
even more clear saying
it is my most attractive trait there you
go hey
listen you you got the feedback you need
i'm not going to get rid of my eyes okay
um
but let's get to the the real part
what's the most attractive character
trait
christy said my ability to love
huh wow my ability to love
you sweet do you do you feel like you
have a high capacity for love
uh you surprised by this answer kinda
we're not
by the way we're not doing the newlywed
game where we're trying to guess what
they said because
ability to done so many times i know
it's not the capacity to love
it's the ability to look like it's like
in practice i'm a lover
battery capacity i love her doesn't mean
battery usage i'm a lover
i'm a lover okay well that makes me feel
nice
i will be making mental note of that
whenever we're like
in a disagreement or a conflict
that be like well if i were to access my
ability to love and then i can solve
that's probably not
strategic uh jesse said
can't decide can't narrow it down
she passed between his humor and his big
old brain
i like when you talk about my big old
brain baby so you sense the humor in
your brain
okay yeah okay i mean if i were to be
paraded in front of a thousand random
people
uh i mean i think my i think i should
have a
relatively small head so i don't think
you would assume that was a big brain
you're dodging the compliment but i do
think which which one you know i'm not
dodging the compliment i'm exercising
the first part which is the humor i
haven't gotten to
being smart yet oh if you can only
choose one of these which one would you
have
chosen because she really needed to only
choose one would you rather be
funny or smart i'd rather be funny
uh i don't i think funny as well
because i don't think that smart does
anything
for you it does things for the people
around you
but i think it makes i i i think it
makes i think
i think funny does more for the people
around you because it is their day well
yeah funny does a lot for the people
around you i'm just saying if you
isolate
smart i mean i and i'm definitely not
i'm not comparing myself to super smart
people but super smart people
are super sad yeah right because they
know too much
and so i don't i don't you know i i
think that smart is g
is is a good quality to have but it's
really i mean i guess you can keep
yourself out of trouble if you're smart
and smart boy stays out of trouble
uh and tell it i mean and like it's it's
nice to interact with somebody who like
knows stuff and then there's like oh
that's interesting
that's thought provoking that's i mean
just edifying
but there's something magical about like
when you make somebody laugh man that's
that's something that's a magical power
i think they're both pretty beneficial
for people around you but i'm just
saying that
for you personally being funny is
probably more fun
let's get let's get to some negatives
what's your husband's worst trait
this is also divided into physical i'ma
let you go first and character
but they but my wife uh took uh
you know what she took she took a she
didn't say like i don't like his nose
she said sensitive scalp
this may seem like an odd answer to you
what is she what is she frustrated
about your senses what is she trying to
do to your scalp that
frustrates her she's rubbing it hard at
any point
in our marriage when she wants to
well first of all now that i've got
these luscious locks that she's so
attracted to
uh any time she's trying to manipulate
them and she like gets a
she snags like if it snags on a ring or
if she's like trying to do something to
my hair what do you mean do something to
your hair
like like style it like fix it or put
something in it or
or something or just touch it like she
might be i'm going to touch your hair
and it's like
i've got stuff in my hair and it's like
my hair is curly so your hands get stuck
in it
and i have it i i'm tenderheaded man and
she's annoyed by me being tenderheaded
she regularly brings this up i will say
that like this is an interesting
like this is the one two punch thing
this is not a you thing this is a you
and her thing because
uh i mean if you want to talk about 100
people surveyed
i think the majority are going to say
that they haven't touched their
partner's
hair like that often like i can't tell
you the last time christie's touched my
hair
well that period i think you're missing
out on a huge
part of what could be a connection
in your relationship that's not what
you're describing you're seeing each
other's hair you're saying
she fixes my hair she puts things in my
hair
it seems like we're talking like nothing
and pruning no i'm saying even if she's
like
i'm you know she's laying there and she
like wants to like
either play with my hair or like scratch
my head or something first of all
okay that's not unusual i don't think no
but that's not what you had described
no but i'm saying she's fixing your hair
well no if she's like
a child before well there's a number of
times that
she like okay i mean it happens more
often than you would think but like okay
when we did that thing where she the
groomer had put
barbara's hair in two ponytails right
and she was like oh let's do
all my good twitter ideas come from
jesse so she was like
let's do that with you and it's just the
process of grabbing my hair and doing
that i mean i'm constantly
that's not a normal relational
application of but i'm saying it any
she just doesn't like the fact that my
scalp is sensitive and it annoys her
because she's touching your hair a lot
but she wants to touch my head
she's touching your hair a lot a little
weird to me but she's not survey a
thousand people i mean if she was
touching my hair a lot even more weird
if a thousand people were surveyed
is it weird for a wife to touch a
husband's hair especially when it is the
number one thing she is attracted to
i believe that 90 i think it's 900 out
of those 1 000 people would say no
that's not weird it's totally natural
unexpected
um christy said my physical
worst trait is oh news flash
my chewing there are times when i'm like
you know what
right now i'm really gonna concentrate
i'm not i'm not chewing like a dummy
i'll own this one dummy i wish i could
fix this
apparently i can't because sometimes i
will try really hard to just chew like a
normal non-dummy what what what do you
mean i'd like dinner
if somebody like notices but like what
how what do you adjust
i just try to shoot slower less more or
less dummy like
it's not a dummy thing i mean you know
what i'm saying it's a level of
aggression
yeah so i try to slow it down
that's still aggressive it's just slower
listen i'm gonna own this one i don't
want to talk about it
okay but i mean god bless her she lives
with you
all i do is work with you and i do eat
on the internet with you quite a bit but
she
she makes meals and serves them to you
and then has to listen to you eat them
she says
beside me did she sit across from you or
next to you
catty corner boy i would be on the other
side of the table
um maybe as far away i said i didn't
want to talk about this okay
this is between us um i didn't talk
about you
and your wife yeah you didn't say a
thing about that
right so what did jessie say is your
worst
character she said he's he's not
a natural snuggler this is not a
character issue
but it feels like an appropriate time to
bring this up also
he believes there's a right or efficient
way to do everything
and that everybody should care about
that as much as he does oh
uh see you guys like me you guys think
that link's the
the only one who's worried about
efficiency my wife thinks that i'm
overly worried about efficiency that's
because she doesn't know
she's she never used the word in a
sentence we use the term efficient she
is right and efficient and
a dash in between it i'm making you a
defender because i think that will
seem heroic but like i mean um
she doesn't place a lot of value on
efficiency let's focus on the i'm with
you on this one
yeah i and i do in my family i am the
one that thinks there is a way to do
things and get
i get frustrated with all my family
members and for the way they do things
uh not a natural snuggler this is true
um but again i'm glad she recognizes
that it's not a character issue
i'm still a good man
but i think that i think that jessie is
an unnatural snuggler
uh-huh i feel like she is on
the far the high end of the spectrum the
hair touching
is a form of snuggle oh 100 percent
so it makes sense yeah so this is
consistent with that it's like
i'm trying to snuggle with you but
you're thinking about your hair natural
snuggler uh
i think the hair touching is is to an
unnatural level as well she is on
she is on one end of the spectrum but it
is not strange i stand by it
it is not strange for a spouse to touch
their spouses no
i didn't think it okay i don't think i i
don't think that's the right word for it
strange or scalp or bush
is it strange for a partner to not touch
their partners but promised we weren't
going to do well
you've wanted me to promise um
chrissy's got my number here with my
character trait that's worse
uh overly critical i mean when we
when we explored the enneagram stuff
it's like you know
again i gotta i gotta own this it was
nice to um
just be refreshed to the impact
that that that has and how like
even though i'm being misunderstood in
my criticism it's like it is important
for me to remember
how how it how it feels to be on the
receiving end of that and
so it's not just about is this important
is this important enough to bring up or
can i let it go
but there's another aspect to the
decision to
speak it in the criticism into existence
and that's
how is this going to be interpreted
how's it going to make
the recipient feel
and um i think that was a nice refresher
there okay we got it but i don't want to
talk about it anymore we got a lot more
to go through but we do
want to remind you that you can get
this shirt um what does it say i can't
read my own shirt
this is your brain this is your brain on
mythical
any questions remember those those
anti-drug commercials from the 80s
this is what this is referring to
if you don't remember it you it just you
might just find this to be a cool shirt
yeah
get it uh mythical.com
okay next question please what's one
thing
that your husband always says to you
christy said i always say to her
did you turn off the lights i do i i
guess i do say that
did you turn off the lights like if i ca
if i could come downstairs yeah if i go
upstairs first
did you turn off the light i'm in the
process of making more of my lights
automatic automatic so i i don't have to
ask her that
this this problem's going away well not
all
i have that in my house and all the
lights
i mean all the lights go off at 1am at
my house
because you never know who's going to be
up past 10 am and somebody every night
except for like some safety lights right
do you still use that um the color
changing
mood they're all still installed like do
you ever
do do that uh
shepard does it i don't really do it
oh you know well occasionally in the
bedroom yeah occasionally in the bedroom
we'll use it
um it's party time but uh
yeah it's party time turns all the
lights on but then i think at 1am they
just automatically shut off
and let me tell you right now
if that doesn't happen none of them
would go off like you could not
the amount of electricity that i'm using
but i do have solar panels
what okay what did you have solar panels
one thing that your husband always says
to you
look at that there to the left you
missed it said as we drive past
something he finds fascinating like a
house
cow tree hill et cetera i am the
king of look at that of pointing things
out and wanting you to look at them
look at that like i mean i know i must
do it
i know it's at least in terms of jesse's
perspective to an annoying degree
because i tend to get really
especially if i'm in a new place i tend
to get really fascinated
with everything and if you're driving
you can't be looking at your phone so
you're having to look at that
all of that and if i'm not driving it's
even worse and then i'm telling
her if she's driving oh she should look
at something but it could also just
simply be
walking look at that and i and
i want everyone to look at it i want all
my family members to look at it
and it seems like even when they look at
it they don't care about it as much as i
do yeah
and i can never get over that may i
suggest a new
catchphrase which is look and care about
that
look and care about that that seems
forceful i feel like i'm just pointing
it out then they can come to their own
conclusions about it it reminds me of my
pet peeve with christy
is when i'm driving and she's navigating
somewhere and she's like
oh turn that way i'm like i'm not
looking at you
i'm looking at where i'm driving like
say left or right give me a
directionality
oh you're going to you're going to turn
up here yeah
up go up turn turn at that sign
which sign which way
like that's why i always insist on like
putting the thing
in the gps because because we just avoid
that fight
technology has avoided so many fights
soon i'll shoot we won't be fighting
about the lights what's the road
when we don't fight about directions
anymore are you telling me that i could
get a robot who just looks at the things
that i ask it to look at oh yeah yeah
hey you know that could be the new robot
hey robot man
look at that and he's like that is me on
form thank you for pointing it out
here's looking at that kid it's a robot
that helps you with nothing he just
looks at the things that you don't want
to look at it can be a child too
and it can be like really into
everything you kind of think it was a
wife you point point
you a robot wife and a robot woman to
look at stuff for you
how about it's just a whole robot family
it's a it's a wife
and two children and they're all and
they travel with us
really into the stuff that you tell them
right yeah yeah
look at that and they're like wow and
but they know but they have like the
built-in technology like the google
thing they're like quoting wiki yeah
they can take a picture of something
that is the hearst castle
founded in 1647 you know
and then they i think they'll be about
it wow dad that's the hearst castle
yeah yeah they call you dad because
because i need to be the one with the
information about it they need to be
wowed by
me they don't need to be telling me
stuff here's a good one
it just happens to be the next question
i'm not they're all good
they're all good they're all great rank
your husband's coolness
from one to ten ten being coolest
okay jesse said eight
negative two for that tiger tank top
and the dad shoes he sometimes wears
tiger tank top
i think i put this on twitter at some
point or maybe jesse did
i bought a series of uh very graphic uh
graphic uh tank tops
back when we thought we were going to do
that character on tick tock he was like
the step dad
he was pretty he had one good tick tock
but we haven't brought him back
uh and i found some funny tank tops on
amazon and then i was like talks on tick
tock maybe i'll just wear one of these
maybe i'll just wear one of these in the
house and see what happens and
jesse didn't like it also that knocked
you down two cool points
well that forever and so i have a few
sort of daddish sort of tennis shoes
that i might wear that are like just
super comfortable or whatever
um jesse will look like ringo starr on a
sketcher's ad
i uh i will definitely defer
to jesse quite a bit when it's just like
how does this look like what does this
look like
and because there are times apparently
like 20 percent of the time
where she's like uh that's i mean no
that's not cool you need to change
that and i trust her in that way so i
totally i'm actually
surprised that you got to an eight that
i got to an eight yeah i don't consider
myself particularly cool
in this way so well christy this is what
she wrote she wrote
uh rank your husband's coolness on a
scale 1 to 10 10 being the coolest
oh gosh 10 plus
then she wrote no one pulls off eating
cereal in a pool floaty quite like link
okay so this is a back candy compliment
this is not a
sincere tin she's saying that i have a
10 plus in coolness
because yes she has
exited the back of our house and seen me
lounging in a pool floaty
uh in my pool eating cereal
in the middle of the day i mean that's
cool it's kind of cool is that cool
she was taking she took pictures what
kind of cereal and what kind of floaty
that's a matter i think it definitely i
think that the
pool floaties like was a six foot tall
sloth inflatable sloth that it see
he seemed to be cradling me because he
was spooning me
or i was you know i was the little spoon
i was
i was facing up that's cool but if the
cereal had the word bran in it
you're not cool oh i'm sure it was uh
well
what about if it's razor brand crunch
doesn't crunch
raisin bran crunch makes you slightly
cooler than raisin bran but it doesn't
make you cool
okay well i got a 10 for my wife uh so
eat that describe your husband
using one word
wow the interesting thing is i think
that
the two things that were chosen for us
by our wives are almost the same letters
rearranged
but not exactly uh jesse
called me an enigma
enigma enigma really
an enigma i guess with one word you
really can't
like expound i know the way i would
describe enigma is like a mystery a
mystery like a closed off
but let me look at the official
definition a person or thing that is
mysterious
puzzling or difficult to understand
i'll take that i mean it's intriguing
uh red enigma mclaughlin so she doesn't
i mean
it sounds like a good name for a pro
wrestler and i think that was
i think that did happen definitely
happened at least once it's several
different levels of wrestling probably
i mean like i've never seen you wear a
mask sincerely
how could you be an enigma uh well i
think where she's getting
i would assume where she's getting this
from is uh
i think her jessie's perspective on me
is that the combination of things that
make up who i am
is not something that she has that she
has run into
and other people she is a she has said
as much to me so you're unique
yeah but in an unexpected way because
it's like it's like in a clandestine way
you could be
unique in like uh oh yeah that guy's
that guy is unique like he wears
books for clothes you know what i'm
saying it's like okay yeah but is that
an enigma
no but if you found out that they got
that that's a weird books for clothes
is also running like a viable candidacy
for president
then you'd be like that is an enigma huh
yeah
you know um christy described me
using the word magnetic
which is also a super that's nice
magnetic code but you know i'm saying
similar letters a lot of letters yeah
but you have these in the next
you have a c and a t that she but
everything else is the same
magnetic enigma magnetic enigma i like
saying that together
magnetic enigma so i'm i'm basically
like
i don't know i i i
come join me in my sloth floaty and neat
cereal with me this isn't uh
so far this is making me my me feel good
for the most part just wait um next
question what's one thing you wish your
husband would
stop doing christy said
listening to his inner critic so she's
becoming my therapist now
in this thing and yeah okay i'll take it
uh
yeah i gotta i gotta i gotta just
i gotta just keep putting that guy in
his place yeah
hey i can mow the grass and think about
other things
you don't mow the grass no i don't
that's one trying to avoid my inner
critic
that's one last thing you can be
critical of yourself for jesse said
jesse said morning farts
when we work out you all work out
together now
you farted up we work out at the same
time working out together
is like doing the same thing
working out at the same time in the same
place
that's how we work out together on our
own programs
every once in a while we'll do like a
you know a little
youtube workout together but but you're
farting well
let's not i said let's i said this i
said this on this podcast earlier i was
like one of the greatest things
about being able to work out at home
which i do now
and no longer going to the gym because
of covet but it's
now i'm never going by to the gym i got
the gym at my house i'm in my garage
right
and one of the things i hate about
working out in public is especially in
the morning you cannot fart
but i you know i like keeping my fart i
like going to the gym and i like i like
having to keep my farts in
because it's like it actually helps with
your form you know you always want your
your glutes tight and your abs tight you
don't want your butt hold tight
you want your butt hold tight yeah you
want your your core tight
you want your core tight which maybe
that'll push a fart out yeah that's what
i'm saying i think i've got the right
technique you got to have a capper
and i have a you got to have a a cap on
the tube and i essentially and also i do
my
whole morning stretching routine which
is like almost designed
you know there's there's like the wind
release pose and yoga or like just
several different poses
that are made to make you fart and i do
those
in the morning and you fight and she
used to not come down there she would
she would come a little bit later oh
well she's come a little bit later and
then she started coming a little bit
earlier and i was like well if you're
going to be in here i can't change this
my body has gotten used to this she used
to work out with me there was a time
there
when i remember the two of us worked out
together we were in we weren't in each
other's homes we were at a digital at
the gym
there was a time in which all four guys
were the same that
but now we never were in the same gym at
the same time
yeah that was we just went to the same
place um
i never recalled hearing her fart
at the gym she also doesn't fart during
our workouts and she's free to do it she
needs to
i just made it clear that i wasn't going
to change my behavior because it was
important for me to be able to
release my wind but she doesn't like it
but i'm like i'm sorry baby this is
something that you're going to have to
deal with
see my problem is when i fart then my
inner critic starts breaking it down
like oh that one wasn't wet enough or
wasn't wet enough next question has your
husband developed any old man traits
in the past few years this is a trap
this is this is a trap question
how are we going to get out of this one
well jessie said
uh morning farts when we work out again
uh and then she added i know this is
interesting and i know that
i was actually telling you in a
conversation we were having yesterday
that she complains about this
complaining about kids these days kids
she has a sometimes i will be talking to
our children
and there's something that i'm kind of
sensing about their generation
that i'm like thinking that needs to be
like addressed
and like maybe called out and you have
to use the phrase
and well i don't go i don't use i
haven't fallen into the
the trope of like saying kids these days
or back in my day
but you know i will sometimes talk about
something that i did like well when i
was your age i would do this
and she's just very sensitive to
me going into that or anytime i'm
talking and i'm talking about
a generation in in general if i'm saying
something about
millennials if i'm saying something
about generation z
she's like oh don't become that guy
you're just falling into it you're going
to become an old guy who just talks
about the problems with the other
generations
so i appreciate this yeah
how are you going to take this feedback
i'm taking it but i'm going to keep
farting but i will stop talking about
the generations but i will not stop
farting because that would be unhealthy
it's like when you when you start in on
that stuff anyone who's in earshot it's
like
it's like a cue verbal cue to just stop
listening
unless unless you're like i might listen
i might commiserate but like if your
kids are in the room it's like that i
mean
they're they're not gonna it's like oh i
gotta stop what i'm doing this is what
dad's about to say
you know it's like that's just not the
the preemptive
that's not the conversation starter that
gets them going you know
kids these days i do not say kids these
days
okay my any old man traits see and this
one
okay it wasn't one what is the most old
man is trait
it's it's old man traits christy said
sleeping with lip balm in a full water
bottle by his bed
yeah is that old man-ish
she goes on yeah she could have she
could have used an excel spreadsheet
wearing a full coat with a cardigan
while drinking coffee at dinner
this is something she made fun of me of
we were sitting at dinner you're always
cold
and i was i was bundled up you look cold
right now i was bundled up and i was uh
yeah my arms are crossed
i'm a little cold and um yeah it was
dinner time and i was sitting there just
drinking a coffee i don't know i was
like i'd forgotten to drink my afternoon
coffee so i'll have it for dinner
you do that if you forget to drink
coffee you have to have it at dinner um
not usually but i did that day when i
was bundled up
i felt i guess i felt old
and then the list wraps up with
consistent
napping and not just consistent
but quick quick draw i i think a
character trait of an old old man
is the ability to nap in any position in
any place yeah immediately and like
we'll go into our office like um
if we're having a long day of shooting
or whatever
uh we'll go into our office sometimes to
like
eat our lunch and then we've got like 10
minutes before we gotta be back
and shooting again and uh
you'll like sit in a chair
it's like to rest your eyes in like
literally like 45 seconds you're like
your mouth opens
and you begin sleeping like i mean i
could lay here
on the couch with no one in here and a
pillow and a blanket it's very
for a long time i would never go to bed
i'm gonna do it i'm i'm gonna be a great
old man
and i'm starting early well the thing is
is that i'm envious of this particular
quality
but i'm i'm fearful if you're this much
of an old man
now and you're only gonna add things on
top of it i'm just
you'll be happy but the people around
you will be miserable
you know you just got to watch out yes
if you kept it at this it's probably
fine
yeah what is your favorite memory of
your husband
oh this would this would be good this is
like
like we're dead so this is it like
what's your favorite
this is what they're going to say at the
funeral uh christy said when we were
dating he covered my car
in heart-shaped post-its i still have
them i think we have a picture of that
in the book of mythical yeah we put it
in the book of myth account she wrote
about it the book
method callie maybe she forgot that but
yeah we still have the post-it notes i
mean
and then i wrote on one of them i'm
stuck on you which is
she left that part out but like that's
her favorite memory of me what's that
she had to go back pretty sure
what have you been doing lately you know
it's like i'm sleeping and eating cereal
in a float
hey she's invited you're not really
building the memories memories baby
oh yeah i gotta do this 20 years have
passed
well when we were dating he put some
stickers on my car
oh man yeah she's got some back-handed
[ __ ] going on here
[Music]
she's hurting that's hilarious she is
hurting me yeah i'm sure you've done
things since then it's just you never
top that
um jesse sometimes when you're filling
out a survey it's kind of like
signing up for a new thing you're like
hey i need a new username and password
right now it's like filling out one of
those things for the kids to let go to
the trampoline place it's like i don't
know he's 17.
um i'm just going to go with my go-to
memory
the this is what jesse said her favorite
memory of me was that conversation
in palm springs when we stared into each
other's eyes
talked about our life journey up until
this point
and both cried oh wow is she speaking in
code
this seems like something it was between
the two of you and it should remain that
way so
uh yeah it was just a it was a moment of
intense
connection okay a moment of intense
connection
you know i don't have any follow-up she
was pulling on my hair really hard but i
wasn't complaining
but i was farting and uh she just deals
with that
um when did you realize
that your husband was the one
okay jesse said it was lots of small
moments
the music he played that first time i
got in this car
the questions he asked me while we
waited for the very late locksmith on
that bench outside a macaroni grill
watching him dance and act completely
ridiculous in front of an auditorium
full of people
and especially when he said if you don't
marry me
who the hell are you gonna marry
that hey that's a pretty good line it's
like it's like it's like
business negotiation it's like who's
gonna give you a better offer
than this well hold on that makes it
sound like she didn't have she didn't
have many she
my wife had if anything had many suitors
um
but the uh yeah it was you know she
didn't think highly of anything she was
she was young you know she got married i
was 23 she was 20.
you know we were on like even the early
for north carolina evangelical
christians in the 90s
level you know timeline so i think the
answer to your question
if you don't marry me who the hell are
you going to marry i think the answer is
well i mean
there a lot of people a lot of people
that i know
a lot of people like to meet what i'm
only 20. what i was implying
and this is says more about me than it
does about her i think
is as i was saying if you're not going
to marry me
please show me the man that you're gonna
marry you know that's
you were right for each other that's who
knew that that's what that's what i was
thinking
uh what did christy say um she realized
that i was the one
spending a summer in santa cruz away
from him
after my junior year in college i kept a
journal of
all of the things i wanted to tell him
but felt like i couldn't yet
because i was i was some robotic stick
in the mud that was like
i don't know what love is yeah if she
had shared that with you it would have
scared you off
probably at the time yeah she she shared
it with me later the floodgates opened
when she returned from santa cruz and we
got engaged that night
yeah you know uh
that's a fond memory what is one thing
that is so classically your husband
classic rat uh
jesse says talking about his food
enjoying his food finishing his food
really quickly
it's yeah it's uh i mean it is an
ability
i'm having a good time when i'm eating
man and i'm talking about it it never
sets up to me to like for it to
disappear so quickly yet
for you to be so engaged in it it makes
sense on one level but it's like
i felt like slowing down would help but
you tell me that's not the case
my philosophy i know some people are
like why do you take the chocolate milk
and drink it all in approximately seven
seconds
and i'm why don't you savor it why don't
you stretch it out i'm like
i'm in it for the peak experience i
don't care how long it lasts
i want it to be as intense as possible
seven seconds and one glass of milk will
be more intense than seven minutes in
one glass of milk
i'm about amplitude man i'm not about uh
longitude or whatever the other part i
don't i haven't taken that
class in a long time yet along with that
speed you are giving constant commentary
about how
amazing it is like when i mean when
we're on the show like
i don't have peripheral vision because
of these glasses and then i mean i just
hear you talking about the food and i
assume you haven't eaten any either and
i'll look over and it's literally i
don't know what i don't
i don't i need to watch the show back
just to know that you're actually eating
it because from my experience you never
you never you're talking about the food
and then it must go it just you must
be dulling it into the can it goes
straight into the can that is my mouth
hole
this is funny because on our anniversary
trip
uh the place that we were staying did
there's not a lot of places to eat in
big sur so the place we were staying
had a restaurant and we kind of and
would do dinner uh every night
and uh it was like a four course
meal and jesse
and i but the funny thing is is jesse
loves to eat
almost as much as i do and loves food
almost as much as i do and eats not as
quickly as me but
very quickly for just a normal person
and what we would we realized
on the second night we realized that
what we would do
is we'd be talking like our conversation
is very like we
there's not a lot of dull moments when
we're on a date together like we're
talking constantly right
and then the waiter sets a course down
in front of us
and we realized it took us two nights to
realize this
that every single time the waiter sat
down the food
we ate it in completion without speaking
you just stopped what you're doing stop
the conversation
just eat it there might be a conversa
there might be like a this is really
good oh yeah this is really good the
conversation is only about the food if
anything is said at all
and then and then it's like it's gone by
the the waiter comes to check oh it's
just over it's you guys finish and then
we get back into the conversation
we weren't proud of ourselves but it was
just a
observation that like man we are really
made for each other because
and jessie said this she was like i went
on dates with a few guys
before you who
if food hit the table it seemed like
they just it
it no it just wasn't a part of it they
didn't realize it
like if i'm in a group and we're talking
and food arrives
and everybody and people don't stop and
acknowledge it and begin eating i'm like
well
you guys need to get your priorities
straight we need to eat the food
and then talk to each other and she's
totally on the same page
to the point of we're not even speaking
when we're eating
so find somebody who likes food or hates
food as much as you do
um chrissy said that what was
classically me was walks around the
house
and checks to see if every light is off
he's going back to this
while singing trace atkins every line in
the house
is all well i do sing that but but that
makes it seem playful
you don't seem mad well at first i'm
like every
light in the house is on you know it's
like at first it is angry and then i
realized
this is a song um
porch looks like broadway and lights
i don't even i don't even like this i'm
not familiar with that song kind of like
noon in the dead tonight who could have
told you that was trey seconds
what does your husband do with the kids
that drives you crazy
okay christy said
link has midnight raid the pantry and
trash the kitchen sessions with lily and
lincoln that look like someone broke in
our house the next morning
okay that's fair i do think that that's
that's that was a very
quarantined thing and it's still a
weekend thing
yeah i try to relegate it to the
weekends now
just the midnight uh kitchen raids yeah
i didn't know that you were part of
these the way that you talked about it
was as if your kids were just doing that
yeah i would get in on it
um jessie said
again this is what does your husband do
with the kids that drives you crazy
joking with them that we would be happy
if
insert something completely ridiculous
here that he doesn't really believe but
knows will push all my buttons
this feels like a very specific thing so
let me explain what i mean because i do
this
a lot so i've never i've never heard you
do this
i don't do this i do this with jesse
because i did it one time
and kind of was joking and it got on her
nerves and then i just couldn't resist
to do it over and over again especially
when the kids are present because i'll
just be like
um we'll be like being a different part
of town
man if we lived in this part of town
we'd be happy or i see like a house up
on a hill and it's really awesome like
man if we lived if we lived in that
house we would definitely be truly happy
and so and of course i'm joking but
it's such a strange yeah i get it it's a
very
it is
it's like once you know that it pushes
her button that's why it's funny
like me saying that me being
discontented
makes you rubs you so much the wrong way
that now this is a joke or we'll have an
incredible meal and i'll be like if we
ate this meal every single night
we would be truly happy and i'm doing it
because
i'm actually trying because there is a
part of me that does think things like
that if we lived in that house would be
true i
i don't really think it but there is a
tendency to always think that the next
thing is better or
where you're not it's better if we lived
here it'd be better and so by
saying it in a joking way i feel like
i'm self-deprecating so
well i'm calling out i'm calling it out
of myself but she has this thing
especially when the kids were younger
oh she thought they're gonna believe
that you they're gonna grow up thinking
that their dad
always thought that if he lived behind
like a giant gate in a castle he would
be truly happy
also like my dad we we did a lot of
stuff and he was never happy
i mean it's like it's pretty simple
what does your husband do with the kids
that makes you extremely happy
okay christy said uh link's nightly
tuck-in routine with lando that's
i mean it's very special for us uh
also she wrote link always finds ways to
connect with each kid on an individual
basis
he watches every behind the scenes lord
of the rings with lily and
most recently bought one wheels for the
boys to get them
out of the house more really smart and
totally worked well it totally worked
for me to then go buy one wheels too
because shepard came over and tried them
yeah
if all part of my plan well if you don't
know what a one wheel is
uh it's a skateboard electric skateboard
with a big wheel just in the middle and
your in your feet go on either side of
it
and you lean forward and it goes it can
go up to like
18 20 miles an hour they're pretty
awesome a lot of fun
but yeah but now my my well shepherd has
one but yeah it's like uh link got some
for his kids
but just just you know i i'm glad she
she appreciate appreciates that i'm not
doing this to make her happy
she loves the kids as much arguably more
than i do so
it's nice that you know she's like oh he
takes time to like do what they want to
do
it it just it's really convenient when
it's also something i want to do
that's why i love having older kids
because you can it's it's
the older they get the easier it is to
find things
that you can get them to do because you
want to do it
like i'm the one getting the one wheel
ads on instagram
i'm the one who's like noticing them
around town and like having the idea
i wanted a one wheel but then i it
clicked into place when i'm like
this would be great for the boys and i
probably wouldn't have bought one
if it wasn't for for that um but like
watching the lord of the rings
i mean it's like this is no sacrifice
this is just this is a win-win
well everything that jesse mentioned is
something that i wanted to do anyway
basketball and or horse horses
is a basketball game we don't have a
horse um
when rhett gets home watching scary
movies together
taking the kids on adventures hiking
camping exploring surfing etc
and then she threw in apologizing when
he screwed up
up which is i mean often
and i um i would be happy if i didn't
have to keep apologizing i do regularly
uh screw up as a father and i do
regularly apologize
to my kids they but it seem they seem to
appreciate it
not the screwing up part but the
apologizing uh does your husband
say or do anything to your pet or pets
that you wish he'd say or do to you
another trap y'all trapping jesse said
everything literally every single thing
he says or does to barbara i wish he'd
do to me
i mean i you know have her perch on you
while you're stretching
here's the thing is that you know she
says i'm not a natural
cuddler but i am a natural cuddler with
barbara
i mean i'm kind of and i'm constantly
the funny thing is is like it's just a
fur bag
i mean yeah of course i i do so much bag
of bones and furniture
baby talk to barbara constantly and i
tell her all this
all this ridiculous stuff about who she
is and what she gets capable of
and uh where she's gonna go in life
which is probably nowhere he's probably
gonna be
in our house but this is a this is a
routine yeah i just
love that dog to death and i'll be
saying these things
and then jesse is like why don't you say
that stuff to me i'm like you want me to
tell you about how you're going to go to
doggy college
it's fun to have an incredible life i
have baby talk with jade
but it's the opposite like because that
i was saying it's a routine
it's a comedy bit that you're doing with
the dog because like you give the right
tone and you know that she eats it up
but you're saying things that obviously
she doesn't understand which is funny
yeah and i do the same thing with jade
but my angle
is the opposite i say things that are
like really
mean but i say it in like a very sweet
voice like i say
you're just a bag of fur and bones
that's all you are it's not too mean but
it's like
you're good for nothing all you do is
you get in my lap and i just like
rub this flesh bag of bones
she might be taking that to her heart
you never know she loves it she loves
every bit of it
and now i mean jasper just cannot get
enough love he needs to just calm down
um what did christy say uh
what do i do with the dogs that
he wishes she wishes i do to her
uh she said spa day with the doggies
okay this is which is true spa day
complete with
full washing massage blow out
and brushing like yeah i i bathe the
the dogs in the garage and i have this
whole
i do this every weekend uh no i mean i
ok i probably should do it i would like
to do it once a month don't you get the
dog groomed
um not over covid and
not every time like for every one or two
times that i watch the dog we might get
it i love barbara
i do not love giving her a bath because
a she doesn't like it
and b it's just a wet when there's a wet
dog it's a tote that's a totally
different thing
they they don't like it jade or jasper
don't like it but
it's still a bonding experience i mean i
i feel like i'm good at it
you're good you can cut hair or be a dog
groomer if that's your back have a
career
well i don't cut their hair no i'm
saying you cut people's hair
yeah i could i could do that it is kind
of related like i have this system of
like
washing and towel drying and then blow
drying i would like to see how
aggressive this is
you've really got to blow dry the dog to
get the poof
and people yeah
viewers will criticize me
for manhandling my dogs but like they
don't
my dogs love me they do not care i do
not
i know they don't care i'm just saying
it is a great it feels it seems
aggressive and i'm just imagining that
the
the the scrubbing and stuff is probably
pretty aggressive
they don't like it so i go i go a little
easier on them
i could give i could give but your wife
wants basically what we're getting at is
your wife wants an aggressive
washing yeah an aggressive washing and a
blowout
what's the most thoughtful thing your
husband has done for you recently okay
so here's your opportunity to shine i
mean 20 years ago you did the
sticky notes yeah recently what are you
doing lately what
would you generate okay christy said
last summer when i was really sick he
would play ray lamontagne's
will make it through a very special song
for us
and he would hold me in bed until i was
ready to start the day well that's
pretty good
that's so sweet um you know eve
for our trip um this past weekend
the present she gave me was uh
ray lamontagne's record with this song
on it
yeah and i remember we did a britain and
i did a listening party around that time
and like i put that song on there
because it was
yeah it was helping us get through and
it was
very special apparently a thoughtful
thing
the most awful thing recently um
jesse said he makes the most delicious
saturday morning scrambles shirtless
for two and he wrote and recorded a song
about our relationship for me on
valentine's day
mythical society perhaps no yes
for now it's just for her um
yeah i got into the to describe the
scramble thing
i heard about yeah christy christie
gives me some subtle digs about um
that you have a scramble morning
scramble morning
uh i well i like to cook a lot and i and
i was and
i've been doing it for years for myself
just like my kids are weird about what
they want to eat and jessie
also has like she's usually like not
really doing carbs or whatever and so i
just kind of feel like i'm on my own
a lot of times and so i'll just go in
there and be like all right what do we
have in the fridge that needs
gotten rid of make a scramble but then
at some point in
during covet she was like well
you're going to make enough for me and
now it's it's
now it's the thing she likes me and you
know yeah
and i keep my shirt off i don't know why
but uh
she requested you know it's just it's
saturday and i'm in my house
it's like getting like egg spatter on
your on your in your belly button
um i mean isn't that kind of the height
of the frying pan
your belly button i got really long arms
what's the craziest thing your husband
has done for you
jesse said i mean the mamoa book
coupled with the 40th birthday video
that included some guy from the insane
clown posse saying he wanted to 69 me 69
ways
can't top that that's true that's true i
think it was 69 69 times
yeah there's only one only one way to 69
but you can't do it multiple times
she got it wrong you need to call her uh
yeah i i don't know what i'm gonna do
for 41
but i knock 40 out of the park um
nothing it resets you started doing
nothing yeah
uh craziest thing that i've done for
christy apparently is
i gave plasma on a weekly basis in
college to fund our dates
this is true and i still dealt with
needle trauma
and still do yeah um
we're telling our neighbors we went we
did a double date with our neighbors
and like somehow that story came up i
think it was fresh on her mind from this
or something
but yeah like we would both thank you we
both go to like the edge of campus and
you have this like place where they
would suck the blood
out of your body into a machine
take the plasma out to make like
cosmetics
and other things things like yeah
there's a lot of things you could do
with plasma
and then they would reverse the system
and put
your blood back into your body i still
don't know how you did it i mean i was
doing it as well but
i didn't freak i thought you just
couldn't handle it and we would get like
20 bucks 20 bucks cash and you could you
could go twice a week
and all you had to do was sit in a chair
and watch incredible hulk on the
television
and wait for april to come up and ex you
know change your needle up
oh yeah i mean that that was pretty
dedicated
okay who would you pick to play your
husband in a biopic
or as we called it until like last year
a biopic
i still think biology still seems like
it should be biopic i mean i know biopic
like
i know what it stands for like biography
by by biopic
a biopic that's how you would say it no
it's a biopic
biography biography and who would you
pick to play yourself
okay christie said uh tim mcgraw and
faith hill
i'd love to see them act together first
of all is this a hallmark movie did tim
mcgraw is an actor this is a cnn this is
a cmt movie
do they have those yeah i'm sure they
have both i mean
faith hill was at the top of her game
when we were in high school christy
did like cosplay as faith hill to like
their like
dance she like wore a dre a white dress
that looked like a faithful dress
i saw we saw in concert back then in
like the 90s i remember she was with
there with uh
i didn't go yeah i think she i think the
brooks and dunn show
faith hill was open for him that might
seem right i could be wrong though
all right uh jesse picked two actors
okay jessie said
mamoa obviously and katherine hahn
who is that for me she's the one that
played the neighbor
in wanda division oh which i was like oh
yeah and the reason she's saying that is
because when that show
brunette was out everyone was telling
her you look like boy
yeah brunette and boisterous okay what
was your first
impression of your husband okay so we're
going back in time christy said
this guy wears really big pants
with way too many pockets
but his eyes are incredible see there
you go
yeah yeah yeah that picture the picture
of the night we met
at the roller skating rink is in the
book of mythicality yeah
so you could actually see my pants
if i wanted to jesse said
tall of course intriguing see intriguing
i think that's what she meant to say
earlier when she said enigmatic
well no because listen she says
intriguing funny
unlike any other person i've ever met
one of a kind
an enigma i think man an enigma there's
a secretive mask
component there's a hidden compartment
the way that this is the way she talks
about it she do she talks about it
like you were from this place
that all the other guys that i had ever
dated or
talked to were from yeah but you seem
like you weren't from this place but you
were from this place
what's what is it about you you're an
enigma okay i'm
well i'm magnetic
um what is one thing most people
don't know about your husband
jesse said it's a good question he's
incredibly generous
generous you tell my charity
how much money are you giving to charity
uh come on
come out with it i'm gonna break out uh
what do you think
quick books what kind what context is
she talking about here she's talking
about like time
money i think she's i think she's
talking about if
if uh if i'm presented with if if
someone comes to me with a need
you know or somebody presents a a
problem or whatever i'm
uh i really enjoy being able to to help
but also i mean that's why that's a big
reason that i like cooking for people
you know it's like it's it's a and not
only is it fun for me but like i
it's true you don't charge for it i i
like
being like hey look at this thing that
you get to enjoy i just i like i like
giving
that way or like hey here's a here's a i
mean you you may not say like
i don't think of red as a gift giver i'm
not really much of a gift giver
but i think it's just uh whether it's my
time or doing something for somebody or
why do you think i keep hanging around
yeah right
uh christy said that the one thing most
people don't know about your husband is
he blow dries his entire body
every morning uh
i think i've told everyone this i think
i've been very open about my
full body blow drying yeah she's just
not listening to every episode of
everybody yeah she's like
she's like surely no one surely surely
he hasn't told everyone about
that i mean i will say
i try to do it when she's not in the
bathroom and it is a bit embarrassing
when you're like
when your legs are spread out so your
ankles are as far from each other as
they can be
and your head is down between your knees
and your blow drying
up into your undercarriage you know they
make a dryer
that you can install in your shop you
don't really want anyone to walk in at
that point you know about this
the shower even a dog right like i've
had a dog walk in on me blow dry myself
and just kind of
look at me shake his head and walk back
out but you know that there is a
technology
where you can put a dryer in your shower
i think that that
that uses too much energy i bet you it's
more efficient than just sitting there
with a damn
blow dryer you know what well not with
my techniques
you know what christy got me for my
birthday
a fancy blow dryer that's what she
bought me a dyson
blow dryer like the one that anna has
yeah like that special
futuristic looking jesse got that ah oh
i love it well i used it like well jesse
used it last night
and it was a very interesting
application that i'm only thinking about
because you're talking about this
last night uh i was getting ready to go
to bed jesse was like i gotta put the
sheets on the bed
and she was like
she put the the mattress cover
over the mattress and then we like put
the sheets on the bed
and did that stupid comforter that you
have to like do inside out and like tie
i'm just i hate making beds but anyway
so
then we get in the bed and she's like oh
man that the mattress cover is a little
wet
do you feel that oh and i was like yeah
it's a little damp
and i wasn't even thinking about it
until you said something
she goes to the bathroom it gets the
dice she gets the dyson
she lifts up the covers she starts
blow-drying always
i don't know how much that thing cost
but let me tell you right now
did it dry well i don't know how much
drying it did
but i told her i was like this is
incredible
like is there an is there an invention
here like the fact that
you're now blowing hot air on my legs
in the bed exactly like right when i got
into the bed yes
and spread your legs and then barbara
but you know like most dogs are scared
of blow dryers like barbara jumps up
there not if you hold him down
aggressively
you think barbara jumps up and then
barbara starts getting into the
blow-drying
stream yeah she's like this and she
starts going under the cover she's into
it
and this just me and barbara getting
blow-dried by jesse in the bed
this is the thing yeah this i'm gonna
get one of these and then i was like can
we do this every night
yeah and you can have a cold blast too
you can have you can just have someone
down there at the foot of your bed and
they can push the cold blast
um okay
last three questions well just actually
two
oh yeah last two questions okay north
carolina or
california
if i'd have really looked at this ahead
of time i'd be like let's take that
question off i don't know if i want to
hear christie's answer i'd be scared
okay but here's what chrissy said my
heart is divided
uh but i'm most definitely a cowgirl
living in los angeles
so yeah it's like a little bit of both
which i i i totally get
and i'm i'm not afraid of the answer um
i knew this is what jesse would say
unequivocally she was she said
california so
yeah she uh we've we spent enough time
in north carolina it's not that we don't
that we didn't enjoy our time there's we
we spend the first half of our lives
there we haven't
i mean and we haven't been home in so
long it's like i mean we're about to go
home
for a while and you'll see how that
impacts christie's answer
all right let's get to this last one if
you could describe your life as a
tv show or movie what would it be
and why okay well
okay yeah i guess i could have guessed
this is the direction that christy would
go in
uh christy said survivor
you know we are we are still i mean
here's what we've done
we watched all the best episodes of
survivor and now we we are going back
and re-watching
episodes that feature characters that
we've grown to love in in
seasons that could potentially be suck
and we'll watch until that person that
we like is voted off and then we'll stop
and then go to another season and keep
watching until it's
it's not good anymore and i just learned
there's a south african
survivor series as well as an australian
one
and um so are you gonna are you opening
up the vault and you're going
through those i think so i don't know if
when lily goes off to college
if the whole survivor thing will um and
as we get totally out of the
pandemic if it will become still
happening nightly
yeah yeah well now it's just the nights
where
no one has plans okay so things are
starting to happen
yeah i mean it would be every single
night even the weekends and now it might
be
we're saying things like i've been
missing survivor it's been four nights
you know so because we're like
somebody will have plans so chrissy said
survivor
we are a tribe of humans struggling
through challenges
searching for rewards and occasionally
wanting to vote one another out
tell me about it i love that
what did jesse say jesse said
lost we've got a lock and a shepard who
are main characters true
we ended up in a place we did not expect
every episode
ends with more questions than answers
the soundtrack is good
the sweet moments keep you coming back
for more even when some wild [ __ ] goes
down
in the end we all make it to heaven even
that even if that pisses a bunch of
people off
spoiler alert that is great
wow we all make it to heaven even though
that pisses us
off yeah this is that's good wow that
was
there's a lot that works there mm-hmm i
you know what we got
we got some good wives man we we are we
are
we are hashtag blessed man
yes thank you to jesse and christy for
taking the time to share those things
with us
and vicariously with you um
they know us so well yeah they still
love us um
do you have a recommendation oh crap
recommendation
uh you know what i want to recommend the
uh audio book for seth
rogan's uh book yearbook d
and i think you might have already
recommended that you
i don't think i recommended it you told
me your biscuit i recommended you told
me to
listen to seth rogan's autobiography
yearbook
on audiobook and i started doing it yeah
and um it starts off funny
but then it once he gets in like the
industry stories that he starts telling
i mean it's just just stories just what
happened
he just has so many good stories i i'll
be honest i don't think i've ever seen
a seth rogen movie really i i i
i know it's not surprising in anybody
because it's coming from me
but i'm actually surprised there's no
way that's true that i've not seen
anything super bad uh
if i have i don't remember you told me
that you watched super bad
i know for a fact you've seen superman
maybe i fell asleep
any my point really is that okay even
maybe i've seen super bad but i don't
remember but
it doesn't matter the dude is just such
a likable guy with great stories
and i kind of love the tone of it i mean
it's i mean
it's what you would expect from seth
rogen it's it could be uh
it can be over the edge depending on
where your edge is
uh well and again he's just so unabashed
in the audio book i'm sure it's great as
a book but the audiobook
in particular he gets where he can
he gets the people who are actually
featured in the stories
to read their lines or some actors and
then they play in there
if you can't if you can't get the person
he gets he gets an actor
so it's a fun listen but it's obvious
really recommending
listening to it yeah when he gets
somebody and you can tell that he was
just like
hey so-and-so i need you to record this
and they were just like i'll just record
it to my phone you know because it's
like right because it's one line
it's just hey and it's i love the way it
came together
you made me you made me watch it so i'm
making them watch it or listen to it
i mean you can watch you can watch the
thing the cursor moving
as it goes all right
and now we're taking the break yes now
marks the beginning of our three
three week break but we'll be serving up
some episodes
in the feed that maybe you want to give
a re-listen to or maybe it'll be fresh
for you uh so we'll keep speaking at you
in that way
and then the fourth
four weeks from now will be it'll be the
present new episode
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best